Monday computers are pretty powerful
things but it's getting increasingly
difficult to make them any more powerful
because it's harder and harder to
miniaturize the basic components that
make them up the transistors so people
have been looking at different models of
computing to try and overcome this
problem and the most promising of these
is quantum computing quantum computers
work in a fundamentally different way to
normal computers a normal computer is
essentially just a series of switches or
bits that are either off or on 0 or 1 in
a quantum computer the fundamental unit
is a qubit in this case they can be in a
state 0 or 1 or a mixed state where
they're both 0 and 1 at the same time
this is a property unique to quantum
mechanics and it's what gives quantum
computers the ability to solve certain
problems a lot faster than normal
computers and to make this a bit more
understandable I'll give you an example
the Traveling Salesman problem here we
have a Salesman who wants to visit
series of shops around town but he wants
to find the route that will get them
around them all in the shortest distance
the way to solve this using a normal
computer is to just step by step through
all of the different possibilities until
you found the one with the shortest
crystal the quantum computer would solve
this in a completely different way
because of the special mixed state
they're able to try all of the different
possibilities at the same time and in
one step find the shortest route this
difference becomes even bigger as you
add more shops for a normal computer
adding one extra shop means you have to
try way more combinations before you
find the fastest route for a quantum
computer it can still do it all in one
step which is pretty amazing so if
quantum computers are so good why don't
we all have one well it turns out
they're pretty difficult to make and let
me show you the kind of things you'd
need to build one
because quantum computers use quantum
mechanics to do their computations
they're incredibly sensitive to any sort
of external noise quantum mechanics is
basically the laws of physics that
dictates sort of the smallest things in
our universe so things like atoms
electrons subatomic particles that kind
of thing so if you're doing measurements
in the quantum world you need incredibly
sensitive equipment and this is the sort
of thing that you'd need to use
so the first thing we need to do is
isolate our qubits from any sources of
external electromagnetic radiation this
can come from external electronics or
mobile phones and to do this what we do
is we hires our qubits in a sealed metal
box and that stops any of the radiation
from getting in and affecting the
measurements another source of noise is
basically temperature so to eliminate
this we need to cool the qubits down to
a few Mille degrees above absolute zero
like minus 270 degrees centigrade and to
do this we place the probe in to one of
these which are basically like giant
thermos flasks full of liquid helium and
they cool the qubits down to very low
temperatures and finally even after
you've done all of this you still have
the problem of how to measure the state
of your qubits this is the most
difficult part because the leads are
used to make the measurements can bring
their own noise to disturb the system so
what you need to do is use really
sensitive electronics and also employ
extensive filtering of the leads used to
measure the qubits so that's it quantum
computers are still in their infancy and
the ones that have been built so far
have only really started to do useful
things
however as experimental techniques get
better and better quantum computers may
well revolutionize the way we do
computing